nearly one in five young children are
not getting enough to eat during that
pandemic and that might be only the
beginning an economic crisis is looming
and the virus might come back in a
second wave well-known NGO is reporting
that the telephones of its domestic
abuse hotline are ringing off the hook
[Music]
the outbreak of the corona virus has
profoundly affected many American
families with millions of low-wage
workers losing income getting sick and
struggling to put food on the table
according to a new survey nearly one in
five young children are not getting
enough to eat during the pandemic food
banks across to you as are struggling to
keep up with demand as hungry Americans
line up for help putting on display how
this crisis is exacerbating long
existing inequalities in American
society the lockdown has hit people in
France's poorest suburbs particularly
hurt one example I was told about is a
young woman who had to stay at home with
her four children and her violent
husband the husband the house holds only
bread owner used to work as a driver for
just above the minimum wage now
unemployed he is receiving even less
money but has to spend more as the
children still can't return to school
where they used to be able to buy a warm
meal for just one euro an explosive
situation and the husband's temper is
getting worse eight associations have
been telling me that the number of
families in the suburbs asking them for
hub has increased tenfold and that might
be only the beginning an economic crisis
is looming and the virus might come back
in a second way
[Music]
here in Germany we didn't have nearly as
tough restrictions as other countries
around the world I would take our two
small children to the park whenever I
want it for example or you could even
buy ice cream over the counter because
cafe stayed open
but the pandemic showed German families
that the country is not nearly as
advanced as it thought it was the sudden
closure of schools and daycare centres
force parents to juggle homeschooling
and working from home and that meant
that inequalities grew because most
schools lacked the technology and
training to provide digital classrooms
and not every family could fill the
learning gap and in most German families
it was the women who reduced their work
hours to be there for their children
putting their careers on hold in South
Africa people are only allowed to leave
the house in the morning for three hours
to exercise or to take the kids out to
play everybody has to wear face masks
and by nine o'clock you have to be home
with the kids schools and preschools
remain closed and the peak of the
phonemic an expected only between late
July and September
if he beats you he loves you so the
saying goes in Russia domestic violence
was already a huge issue in the country
it's considered an administrative rather
than a criminal offense but like in many
countries things have gotten worse in
lockdown one well-known NGO is reporting
that the telephones of its domestic
abuse hotline are ringing off the hook
and many people just have nowhere to go
because shelters have gone into
quarantine as well one group of
parliamentarians recently asked the
government to open additional shelters
and in the meantime there are reports of
some hotels across the country opening
their doors to domestic abuse victims
[Music]
in this residential area invade with the
capital of Lebanon family reunions
usually take place in houses like the
ones you see behind me but after the
Lebanese government boost a total
lockdown Ahmet coronavirus rising cases
streets became almost deserted and warm
reunions that gathered members of the
same family now turned virtual and while
video calls served to connect the
Lebanese residence with the Diaspora are
now a tool of communication to connect
family members residing in the same city
[Music]
one particular challenge that families
are facing right now is accessing
general medical help and consultations
with doctors this is especially true for
expecting mothers children and senior
citizens they have now resorted to
consult with doctors online